so whether you're a wonder woman or busy
executive evolve whole health has what
you need to keep going strong so
co-founder of evolve whole health dennis
carter and nurse practitioner chris
kleinman are here to explain what all of
that means i like the idea of wonder
woman though hey yeah i like that idea
all right so what is evolv whole health
great explain it yeah so evolvable
health what it really is is it's a
membership based
whole health approach to your
preventative medicine okay right so it's
going to be everything's included right
you don't have to try and piece it all
together right if you need because
that's where it gets complicated that's
where it gets complicated right so it's
like oh well i need some hormone
replacement therapy i got to go here or
i need to join the gym so i'm going to
go there and i don't really know what to
do about my nutrition so i'm going to
try this place right so this is this is
a whole health approach from a
membership-based standpoint right to
tackle all of that together okay and
this is the physical place you walk into
you get you get help right there it's
but it's different from a med spa
correct so yeah that's a good point so
uh med spy is one component of could be
one component of the membership okay
right because we're focused on whole
health so it's internal and external
gotcha so our members really like to add
med spa right services to their
membership
but we're not a med spa but that's one
of our affiliates so runs plastic
surgeries med spy is one of our
affiliates and so that's a really
popular add-on to your membership okay
well speaking of add-ons memberships
what does the package entail and i know
it's specific for your own needs which i
love absolutely um so there's a lot of
different memberships but some of our
most popular ones um are really our
memberships are focused on needs right
right so myself and my in my coat my
business partner dr brandon reynolds you
know we we tried to identify needs
and then build the packages around those
needs okay so okay you know something
like a hormone replacement therapy
essentials that's really focused on you
know that maybe that individual who just
needs a little bit of pick me up right
but done in a way that's monitored by a
medical professional and it's done right
okay so that brings me to chris yeah so
for example if i'm coming in for a
consultation what are you gonna ask me
what do i need to be prepared to answer
uh
well we would probably ask you about
your entire life your sleep your
exercise routines your nutrition
everything all the ins and outs of you
and then find out where you're
lacking in some of the pieces and then
where we can improve those and
it's a lot of little tiny adjustments to
make somebody a
better person over a long period of time
this isn't like a short
game we're not trying to
you know i know it's around new year's
but we're not trying to short game
anything we want long term
i'm not going to ask you to do anything
that you can't do for a long period of
time this you're investing in your
clients right i love that i love that so
how quickly can patients see results or
you know a success story
uh usually that's based on the
motivation involved in the individual
but we've seen plenty of people we had
some of our first ones go from about 22
body fat i had one go down to about
seven percent body fat in about
nine months
but he sustained that over the last 18
months so it's more of a long
term is what we're looking for oh i love
this is such a great thing to have here
in our community how can people get more
information really quick yeah so go to
our website evolve wholehealth.com uh or
give us a call
and talk to our 702-849-09 concierge
thank you guys so much we appreciate you
j.c awesome to you